Kaymer the senior would three to shoot
they call Big Shot Perry off the court
offense clock there have been six that
could be a game-changer that mistake in
my reddish back down to what a turn of
events right there that was a five-point
swinging a layup missed layup missed up
opportunity wasted a lot of time
Williamson driving taco as the basket
Steve on your shoulder big time delivery
thousand kids man well this was a one
all won in the end with two guys with
four fouls it wasn't a dunk on taco but
it's the liver and it was his best
saying this guy right here all night
when his team has needed him a free
throw to tie it 5 out of 6 at the line
Vista comes up short okay Barry time and
time again step it up big you got to
block out and with no taco on the floor
to that influence those inside or
outside positions I should say about
that talk about lint coming in handy
guys was set up now as you see again the
put back off the missed free throw for
the lead now you got one the shocker
here we go inbound up to Taylor Jones's
on him Taylor driving driving and backs
it up though just barely
you can't get any closer than that
unbelievable opportunity first in shot
tailor and then the follow point-blank
great looks there BJ Taylor got the shot
he wanted an arbor Dawkins have done it
all off bad and he is brokenhearted at
the end of his play and in and out yet
what an effort by that can all game long
ha ha ha
[Music]
look at this tennis this tap tried every
which way possible to go down hug on the
rim